Hi, I'm Wilbur,...
...and I've noticed that everyone's talking about one thing lately: Christmas!
I decided to ask my friends at Webcertain what all the fuss is about,...
...and they told me that Christmas is a very special time of year...
...that's celebrated differently in different countries.
My friend Barbara is from Italy,...
...and she says that a very important part of an Italian Christmas is the nativity scene.
Most families have their own miniature nativity scenes that they put up at home,...
...but the baby Jesus is not put into his crib until Christmas Day.
Food and family are very important at this time of year,...
...and families come together to feast multiple times throughout the festive season.
Another popular Christmas family activity is playing tombola,...
...which in Italy is similar to a game of bingo.
Christmas celebrations last from the beginning of December...
...all the way to the beginning of January,...
...and on the 6th of January, a good witch known as "La Befana"...
...fills the children's stockings with sweets if they've been good,...
...and coal if they've been bad!
I hope you've enjoyed learning how they do things in Italy.
Happy Christmas from everyone here at Webcertain!